the incredible visual effects in today's
films demonstrate that anything is
possible and that even the most
fantastic images found in the pages of a
screenplay can become an on-screen
reality effects artist working in
concert with virtually every department
apply their expertise to serve the story
and to make the audience believe that
even an ordinary man can climb walls
spin webs and swing through the air here
are the nominees for achievement in
Visual Effects Blade Runner 2049 John
Nelson geerdon Epson Paul Lambert and
Richard R Hoover need guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 Christopher Townsend Guy
Williams Jonathan Faulkner and Dan sudoc
Kong Skull Island Steven Rosenbaum Jeff
white Scott Venza and Mike mine artists
Star Wars the last Jedi Ben Morris Mike
Mulholland Neal Scanlan and Chris Korbel
[Applause]
more for the Planet of the Apes Jolla
Terry Daniel Baron Dan lemon and Joel
wit and the Oscar goes to Blade Runner
2049
this is
and fourth nomination for John Nelson
and the first Oscar and third nomination
for Richard Hoover your nets are Paul
Lambert our
[Applause]
yes thank you so much
Academy members of cabinet for this
great honor Thank You denis villeneuve
who's you know guts are seen in every
frame of this film especially the visual
effects thank you Andrew Kossoff
Broderick Johnson Roger Deakins Joe
Walker Dennis Gassner bill Carell Karen
Murphy
Richard Clegg Habib's a gap or up there
in the rafters D Koran Victor Muller
Cynthia Arkin Dean egg Frank's tower mbc
booth Rho dou P P atomic Wetty elk on
Warner Brothers Sony Sean young Deb and
miles and this is so surreal I share
this with my incredible team led by
Michelle back a double- my family
especially for putting up with the crazy
hours of the last 22 years
hopefully my boys Boston Oh Jackson are
watching right now and to all the people
who have had such a big influence on me
and my career
thank you
come on my friends in Montreal merci
beaucoup this is for you
danke Schon Germany thank you great